paulette oyane ondo bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin on le disait départ précipité
donc de quelques 450 casques bleus
gabonais en centrafrique après des
accusations d'exploitation et d'abus
sexuels une enquête est ouverte alors
sur les faits quels sont les indices
aujourd'hui graves qui ont justifié
cette décision qu'est ce qu'on en sait
ce qu'on sait c'est qu'elle est et ce
même pour la première fois pour le
contingent de casques bleus gabonais
déjà un
2014 seize parce que le gabonais avait
été accusé des mêmes faits et avait été
exclu du contingent de l'onu est notre
envoyée au gabon les autorités
gabonaises avaient promis une coquette
jusqu'à présent nous n'avons pas des
conclusions de cette enquête alors
pourquoi justement
pourquoi justement cette enquête n'a pas
abouti
je ne sais pas pourquoi ça
on sait pas que je te croise un matin
d'août et puis surtout on se focalise
toujours sur
les hauteurs mais on oublie les victimes
c'est comme une petite fille de 12 ans
10 ans présent c'est terrible et
personne à voir ces petites filles parce
qu'ils sont des victimes
et que comment est ce que les les
autorités centrafricaines réagissent
parce qu on se souvient en mars 2018
avec le sous fond d'eux mêmes
accusations le président faustin
archange touadéra avait refusé le départ
des gabonais à ce moment-là
ça c'est peut-être des questions
politiques
mais aujourd'hui c'est à cette époque la
ccss gabonais aujourd'hui c'est de 360
vous parliez des victimes vous parlez
des victimes justement est ce
qu'aujourd'hui elles sont prises en
charge par les par des associations par
les autorités
oh non je ne pense pas elles ne sont
plus un chat sympa personnes on les
oublie les victimes elles sont elles
sont carrément des victimes a
complètement abandonné et c'est là le
vrai scandale au scandale et de niveaux
solo et
les autres de me sens jamais vous et il
est au fait que les victimes
et en plus on peut même se demander tout
ça se tient cette présentation tout
chaque musée lui même a coulé à saint
pierre parce que depuis les protégeant
de l'onu sont incertains
si kim caughey semble pas assez tenu d'y
mettre la sécurité
ça n'a pas changé
effectivement l'onu qui n'arrive pas à
endiguer qui n'arrive pas en rendiez ces
accusations ou 19 heures
oui le nul et d un dicton mieux les
hommes la manière suivante wahou mieux
je n'ai pas le bois je n'ai pas la
possibilité de tenir quitte ce soir
c'est le problème des états membres donc
chaque état n'aura qu'à punir les 70
soldats qui sont des casques bleus de
l'onu l'onu considère qu'il ne peut pas
lui le faire parce que le juge est une
émanation et mais 180 du nombre d'états
qui composent la cour les zones de l'oni
donc c'est plutôt c'est au gouvernement
gabonais ne sanctionner les casques
bleus qui ont été renvoyés et qui sera
impliqué dans ces accusations
exactement seulement l'évoquait ouvert
non mais t'es jamais
avoir les gabonais de maintenant il y
avait des gabonais de 2014 avant et
maintenant l'éternel aujourd'hui mais
avant ça parmi les soldats français
oui ne sont pas celles qu'on était aussi
accusé d'abus sexuels les sondages ainsi
souhaité appeler la le sexuel le
gouvernement pensait les artistes
supplice mans au soustrait de
l'indignation populaire
et les victimes n'ont pris
la population centrafricaine avec toutes
ces affaires quelle relation est là
aujourd'hui avec les forces de
musica
à mon avis une relation bien désastreuse
quand même parce que quand on voit que
le la musica et la barre que plus de 20
ans elle y est allée prétendument et les
mettre la sécurité et lutter contre
les terroristes le terrorisme et
canapés aux deux opérations ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui c'est que si l
instabilité à
s'intéresser à la sécurité qui
reviennent un scientifique c'est parce
que la centrafrique a eu l'intelligence
de copiner avec une autre puissance et
puissance habituelle avait l'habitude de
jeter alors le lot est nul
le lot est venu à établir un code de
conduite pour temps mais il n'est pas
respecté
mais le coup de caen du soleil des mous
ça risque de répéter d'autres gens
bourson ce que nous demandons c'est que
des gens qui veulent des petites
histoires unis et que les victimes
soient dédommagées les victimes c'est
très curieux que personne si ce n'est
celui ci jamais les victimes c'est quand
même temps que vous lisiez de la
jeunesse d'un pays c'est vous les
esprits sans armes ils n'oublieront pas
de sitôt de cette situation et
malheureusement
les casques bleus de l'onu sont tues tu
veux des fonds et s'installe depuis les
années 90 ans en 93 en attente de plus
des années 90 ont peu en commun et puis
un article intitulé les casques bleus de
standards en scandant qui
a mal qui non seulement il fait quelques
fois nous apportons maladie
ils n'ont jamais voulu admettre la
famille la population haïtienne
défenseurs de droits de l'homme se bat
qui connurent angoisse enfin que
l'europe et mes moutons on a pas il ya
pas eu de demain dommage moi le plus
impacté par boni
suite ce
n'est pas à lui de le faire merci à vous
paulette oyane aux dons d'avoir répondu
à nos questions ce matin je rappelle
vous êtes avocate au barreau du gabon et
défenseur des droits de l'homme